- Welcome to the Kelly Clarkson Show,
give it up for my band, y'all.
(audience cheering)
I love that song so much.
Trisha Yearwood was one
of the best singers-
- Kelly.
- On the planet.
- Kelly, hey.
(audience cheering)
Hey I'm back, hi.
Joel McHale, thank you
for having me on the show.
- (laughing) Are you-
- Again, thank you-
- Why are you doing this?
- For having me, thank you.
- You were here yesterday,
what are you doing?
- I was here yesterday,
thank you so much.
- You're sporting my jacket.
- Thank you, it's great
to see you guys again too.
Hey, Kelly, I am Team Kelly, as you know,
and it was my fourth appearance
on the show yesterday,
you gave me-
- You got the jacket.
- This amazing pink lady's jacket,
and I just love it.
(all laughing)
I love it, and now that
it's my fifth appearance
on the show I was just dying
to know what the prize was.
- No, I told you, I told Joel yesterday
there would be a gift
for his fifth appearance.
This is cheating.
- You did.
You said that.
- You're, (laughing)
- I mean, you said that.
- You're lying, this is not an appearance,
this is you showing up, crashing.
- You two dimensional people
heard that, right? Right?
(all speaking in agreement)
So, I get-
- No, you have to come back for real-time.
- Well I feel like I could just-
- You didn't bring any animals
this time, I'm disappointed.
- No, I mean, I am an animal,
if you know what I mean, guys?
(all laughing)
But I'm just gonna take something, so,
- What?
- This is gonna be mine.
- Oh my gosh, no.
- You know what, not that,
I'm just gonna take a prize
for my fifth appearance.
- You don't get to take-
- Thank you.
- That's called stealing.
- You know what,
I'm just gonna grab one of these.
- [Kelly] You are not grabbing a guitar.
- So, uh, thank you, thank you so much.
- You are-
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Are you, you're
taking two guitars.
- Yeah, just-
- [Kelly] You know what?
Okay. It's not a gift-
- This is great.
- [Kelly] If you take it.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Okay-
(guitars clattering)
- [Kelly] Everything-
- It's all right,
it's all right, it's okay,
I got 'em, I got 'em.
Thank you. Thank you Kelly Clarkson,
great show, great show.
(guitars clattering)
(Kelly laughing)
(audience cheering)
- It's okay. Security will
stop him, our department.
He's a thief, he does steal,
Lisa Vanderpump was right.
Okay, as I was saying,
give it up for-
- I'm taking this too,
this platinum record, thank you.
(record clatters)
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
Oh my god, I love him.